an important donor to president Trump's
campaign reportedly worked to create a
private line of communication between
mr. Trump Russian President Vladimir
Putin the FBI declined to comment on
this last night on whether it's
investigating this matter The Washington
Post reports the secret meeting involved
the founder of the Blackwater security
firm who has ties to the Trump
administration figures major Garrett is
at the White House with a new twist in
the Trump rushes story major good
morning good morning Eric prince was a
donor to the Trump for president
campaign he's also the founder of a
private security firm implicated in a
2007 wartime massacre in Iraq Prince's
allege to have met a putin confident
just nine days before mr. Trump's
inauguration according to the post the
United Arab Emirates reportedly arranged
the meeting in the seychelles islands in
the Indian Ocean Prince's aim was to
establish a back-channel line of
communication between Moscow and
president elect Trump the White House
denies knowledge of the meeting and
princes representatives deny it had
anything to do with the president prince
was an outspoken supporter of mr. Trump
during the campaign giving more than two
hundred thousand dollars to his election
efforts his sister is mr. Trump's
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos in
the midst of ongoing investigations into
Russian meddling in the u.s. election a
source close to former Obama National
Security Advisor Susan Rice confirmed to
CBS News that rice had asked for names
of the trump team to be unmasked to her
after seeing them referenced in
intelligence briefs identities of us
civilians caught in foreign surveillance
are normally concealed or masked there
is a troubling direction than some of
this is going in White House press
secretary Sean Spicer said the focus
should be on obama administration leaks
the deputy assistant secretary for
defence for russian affairs said very
publicly that this was part of an
attempt of the obama administration to
spread classified information as
national security advisor it was within
Rice's authority to request the
unmasking of names however the source
said rice did not ask that the names be
distributed through the intelligence
community as members of the Trump White
House continue to allege
and I was not aware of any orders given
to disseminate that kind of information
the president's son-in-law jared kushner
whose responsibilities appeared to grow
by the day met in baghdad yesterday with
the iraqi prime minister to discuss
whether US military advisors can leave
that country win as planned the key
northern city of Mosul is liberated from
Isis the White House denied that Kushner
was overshadowing national security
advisor HR McMaster or Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson neither of whom
Gayle has been to Iraq all right major
thank you very much